hello I'm getting the hang of this
Margaret Cho we're gonna do it and it's
going to work don't whip right do it
good in your food like you should know
if you guys don't know us
you're an idiot whatever be a better you
this year yeah new you new new
Wow I had a stroke and you can tell this
is our second video we've shot we might
have heart sail no year new us if you
guys don't know us oh my name is Maura
Cho no relation I am grace helbig's on
and my name is Club Doris tremble and I
am
mamrie Hart or they have so graciously
given over the YouTube channel they did
not you know good and why we broke it
yeah we guess the passcode you know
throw in a couple 69 and a couple
characters from the TV show blossoms Oh
Luanne we act into the mainframe we made
a video over on memory quartz channel
you know new year new eyes we want to
find love we've been trying to hook each
other up and let me tell you it took a
tory who okay but now we're gonna skew
younger okay we're gonna be hit this
year we really want to take on youtube
with Korea's seriously we hit that
YouTube is flourishing there's zero
drama on it and we thought that seems
like a safe place to be creative let's
get in there they seem accepting of all
ages we are going to start looking
through some very popular youtubers I'm
gonna be when it's with you hundred show
yep I don't really watch youtubers
except for our nieces and most of the
time I watch our nieces just to see when
they go out of town so we can break into
that Palm Springs house and you to the
pool of your belief that clitoris
trembles
I did not somewhat just jump that's like
a long rolled in like into the pool I
sunk like an anchor this woman had to
pull me out she went in for
mouth-to-mouth and I was like I was a
boy and then I was breathing again EMT
first responder only responding to thank
God I was awakened and didn't take my
sleeping pills that would have been Oh
yikes you guys sent tweets tweets are
you want to tweet at Grace's and she
sent me these photos she asked you guys
who are your favorite youtubers are and
we're just gonna go through them and let
you know what we think of them if
they're their favorite youtubers it
better just be pictures of our nieces
who should we stop with I don't know my
eyes are closed this one's name is tone
of Franta oh she's beautiful
Wow Wow I would like to know why is she
wearing football pants I mean I was
going to say it's kind of showed us to
here that would be difficult in a small
doorway that'd be very difficult on a
plane oh my god you have to buy 3c oh I
love a great turtle I am a connoisseur
of turtlenecks you are connoisseur
okay what kind of content do we think
Corner me hmm
his own clothes yeah corner looks like
she'd have very soothing voice yes maybe
he's like sneaking stuff into the movies
you know how you and I Oh meals into the
movies yeah oh man a punku and the hood
scene up in nutshell onto the next two
weeks okay closing my eyes - yes it's
okay we got these there Oh Veronica Mero
the twins they look adorable Wow Oh
twins scare you the way they scare me
are you yeah I can't do anything but I
can't even eat Twinkies or things that
come in twos
I don't like identical Hey yeah that was
a terrible fourth of July these are
gorgeous approachable twins they look
like they don't cos they look like they
make a relatable content where it's like
hey you now we're gonna tell you like a
things
make for lunch yeah meal prep yeah
temples Jesus well you can hide like a
whole suitcase I was gonna say you won't
have to carry your purse to stick your
keys in there
okay here's next copy oh I don't get it
what is it I think she's a robot
just from the Justin Timberlake music
video thank you we think she's the first
youtuber robot getting like a religious
vibe yeah she's a religious robot
oh no she's a Scientology so
Scientology's a saint all that's what
that's what Scientology is I don't want
to watch you poppy but you can hook me
up with Tom Cruise oh oh don't get us
started
oh my god okay here we go closing my
eyes oh man we got Scott and Mitch
what's going on here this looks like a
Salvador Dali painting it sounds like
boy I don't get I mean yes alright do
you remember my aunt Clarisse oh yeah
she had that dress she said she was
buried in oh wow wow I'm attracted to
both of me too especially the one on the
right though what is he a Viking do you
the Viking that owns a catering company
I thought what that channel is do are
they cater us you know that HGTV shows
with the husband and wives they do the
houses they flip-flop in it yeah they
look like flips apply flips and flops it
flips and flops
oh my going from the top to the bottom
did you hear Joanna Gaines it's pregnant
again
oh I thought this is closing my eyes
this is Shane Dawson and Rylan ball
other twins is the twins again Oh
another twin Channel do we need to get
like matching hair cut well go ahead
this one bleep comment oh yeah okay
you're not going straight I'm broken for
this means you know what especially the
one on the right looks like he makes
really wholesome gruntin
they look like those twins that can
communicate telepathically I'll be like
what am I thinking the other one will be
like that you love your brother and he's
like yeah Oh brilliant well
will I will and Wilhelmina Wilhelmina Oh
God could you imagine taking four belts
in your closet and turning it into a
dress my God look at those gams those
hands just got ham dams hey yeah oh my
god those dams coming in honey and
roasted very slowly in a rotating motion
this one is way off is that her tongue
she should see a doctor
we have great doctor recommendations if
you're ever looking to true could do a
makeover oh let us make you all the
monsoon the storm is coming put on the
poncho and get your butt over here cuz
we're gonna fix that weird finger braid
yeah and we got a weirdly cannot ceiling
- so you just what we just want you
group of them I'm scared
eyes open okay I die hey wow I thought
they were cold Oh like a bunch of mimes
it's like Steve Jobs having like an
intern program do we need like 14 more
people for our youtube-channel
turtlenecks is a big theme with all
these success you know I feel like I'm
already like on board you gotta turn why
did you tell me I'm sorry and get you a
turtleneck and I made eleven more people
they look kind of similar the rest 11
more non-diverse people maybe one or two
we need eleven Caucasians we cannot call
case one very adorable Indian girl a
couple I could go anyway I mean sideways
okay okay this one's name is Jenna Oh
Janice seems my speed if I didn't know
this is a computer
I'd be like we're looking into a mirror
don't even being optimistic your glass
is half-full girl life is gonna be fine
in 2018 your future's so bright you had
to wear shape hey we've always said our
biggest dream is being weekend at
Bernie's
I have no idea but she's having a great
time regardless okay I think I don't
want to look at him so that's the end of
the video I feel that we've really
immersed ourselves in YouTube culture I
think we're one of the we're in it now
well I'm into it I think we should
explore I think you know new year new us
and what we should oh you know we should
every once in awhile you and I try a
different type of YouTube video yeah
didn't see what really our vibe is we
have to explore new auction it wouldn't
be new year new us unless we tried a
couple of different things so let us
know in the comments what types of
videos you guys want myself included or
us to do over the year 2018 and make
sure you guys go over the memories
channel and see basically I know
husbands that we found for each other
get ready if the male model on the front
of a romance novel does not have
healthier hair than me I'm not reading
it well I gotta say it wouldn't be that
tough what's going on up there
we'll talk about it later I did an egg
bath 12 Cotton's